le pregunto Cuál es el balance de este
de estos meses de mandato para Gustavo
Petro Cuáles son un poco los logros y
los déficits de su mandato bueno con las
buenas noches muchas gracias a ustedes
por la invitación creo que estos han
sido diez meses bastante movidos para la
política creo que en términos positivos
se han abierto diferentes agendas
políticas de discusión como temas de la
salud temas del trabajo entre otros que
por años se digamos se congelaron con
una reformación en detrimento de las
personas de los ciudadanos y que creo
que es positivo para una democracia
nuevamente abrir Estos espacios de
discusión lo malo es que creo que el
presidente pues entendiendo que solo
tiene cuatro años y ganó con una campaña
de esperanza y de cambio sabe que tiene
que acelerar la agenda digamos la agenda
en el congreso para esta reformas y se
le ha dificultado creo que lo malo es
que no ha sabido plantear tampoco el
debate Así como tampoco ha sido Clara la
hoja de ruta para el presidente hacer
estas modificaciones hay reformas que sí
las Ha abordado con los sectores que se
digamos encargados o los sectores que
reúnen estos temas Pero hay otras que no
Entonces creo que ha sido unos diez
meses de bastante Movimiento Político
con algunos escándalos pero que igual el
presidente pues tiene todavía un tiempo
suficiente para poder redireccionar esta
agenda y reconfigurar su correlación de
fuerzas en el congreso y en las calles Y
particularmente para redirigir esta
agenda como usted nos menciona y para
sobre llevarse a los obstáculos que
tiene en el parlamento concretamente
cómo lo puede hacer Gustavo Petro para
ejecutar Este cambio profundo que
prometió al país deben movilizarse las
calles tal y como ha pedido Petro Bueno
yo creo que tiene que tener varias
estrategias la primera de ellas es que
tiene que mejorar sus estrategias de
comunicación Creo yo que no ha sido
acertado en la manera como se ha
expresado el presidente y la
vicepresidente por sus redes sociales
entonces creo que tiene que ser más
asertivos y atractivos en ese aspecto lo
segundo creo que tiene que crear una
estrategia que movilice mucho más el
gabinete con el congreso para poder dar
digamos abierta discusión a las reformas
y en el tercer caso en el sentido de las
calles yo digamos creo que Obviamente el
presidente quiere reforzar su capital
político electoral que fue el que lo
llevó a las calles Si eso desconocer que
el otro 49% de la población pues no lo
apoyó a él vale Creo yo que en relación
con eso él tiene el derecho de seguir
manteniendo su apoyo de su de su
electorado Pero tiene que tener cuidado
no caer en tratar de suplantar el estado
de opinión con el estado de derecho creo
que aquí el presidente tiene que tener
claro que el estado de derecho tiene que
primar por encima del del estado de
opinión y de las calles y que por el
contrario tiene que seguir abriendo
Estos espacios de discusión y debate no
solamente en el congreso no solamente
con Los jefes políticos de los partidos
sino creo que también tendría que abrir
más espacios políticos para escuchar las
diferentes voces de la sociedad
colombiana
Manuel brevemente le pregunto Qué tan
lejos está el proyecto de paz total
prometido por a Gustavo Petro tenemos
muy poco tiempo así que le pido que sea
sintético no es una aspiración que sin
duda alguna creo que los colombianos
deseamos que requiere muchas estrategias
pero creo que aquí hace falta es tener
una hoja de ruta mucho más clara en
donde se pueda establecer una Clara
estrategia con el eln que es una
organización alzada en armas pedrada y
Que obviamente tiene un mayor una mayor
dificultad de negociación con esta
organización alzada en armas distintas a
las FARC Entonces quiero que el trabajo
es arduo falta bastante lo positivo es
que ya hay unos acuerdos sentados sobre
la mesa y que creo que hay que reforzar
estos acuerdos
exigiéndole a la Elena y las garantías
suficientes pero sin sin dejar caer la
fuerza de poder mantener los diálogos
con este grupo guerrillero sin duda
alguna en la tarea es ardua y
necesitamos mayor trabajo y una ruta más
clara frente